Let's take a closer look
at each round of AES.
Again, in AES,
data is represented as state array.
The first operation is substitute bytes.
This involves using S boxes to
perform byte by byte substitution.
And again,
the result is stored in the state array.
The second operation is shift rows.
And this is permutation
that's performed row by row.
Again, the result is in the state array.
MixColumns is a substitution that
alters each byte in a column
as a function of all
the bytes in the column.
Again, the result is in the state array.
And then we XOR with the round key.
The result is in the state array, and
this feeds to the next round of AES.
As you can see, each round of AES
involves substitution, permutation,
which represent confusion and diffusion,
and also use the encryption key.